what percentage of your viewers do you
think have seen one of my videos before
what percentage of the viewers on
YouTube right yeah that's your viewers
of the viewers on YouTube though yes
okay sure or all of them it's just
interesting because you're you're
speaking very specifically like about my
brand deal process and so in my head I'm
like I wonder what percentage of these
people even have any idea what he's
talking about that's interesting I love
the thinking about numbers the whole
time we're having this conversation
that's all I could think about is like
God damn it he's there's probably like
50 of these people have no [ __ ] clue
what he's saying and we're about to
torture him for five minutes yeah yeah
probably but that's something I can't
turn off in my brain less than 50 is
that a good thing or a bad thing is that
exciting to you that that there's like
50 of people don't I've not watched the
Mr Beast video isn't that an opportunity
like yeah I guess there's an opportunity
to grow I don't know honestly I was just
kind of excited to hang out with you
yeah yeah me too I mean who cares yeah
so it's kind of like having a buddy to
go along the journey as I'm just kind of
eating [ __ ] and doing my normal ride it
was like kind of fun and also you just
say really wise stuff constantly so
honestly no I never even put any thought
into like that demographics of what I
could gain it's just interesting because
like my retention brain when you talk
about something I'm instantly like hmm
what value are they gonna get how many
of them are going to be interested what
percentage of people do I think we'll
lose and I'm like running all those
calculations in the background and that
whole conversation like the law is
anyway it's just something I can't turn
off my like Bells were like this is bad
what are the different strategies for
high retention for your videos in
general it's like how do you cook good
food you know what I mean that's like
the same kind of question I see so
there's so many different ways that you
so it boils down to I mean
uh do you think it's at the level of a
story or do you think like literally
watching five seconds at a time am I
gonna tune out here am I gonna tune out
here am I going to tune out here it's
all of it you need the overarching
narrative and then you also need the
micro where every second you know needs
to be entertaining and you basically
what's interesting is the longer people
watch something the more likely they are
to keep watching so you don't have to
try as hard in the hypothetically back
half of a video as you do in the front
like even right now we're so deep into
this where a lot of people listening are
probably just going to keep listening
relatively close to the endless we just
have a really boring part of this
conversation because they're just
they're saying it they're they're
immersed
um and so a big like to really boil it
down to a simple level you just want to
get people where they're immersed in the
content and then just kind of hold them
there